hi abigail it is so nice to meet you
uh welcome to the 16 in pregnant
universe how have things been going
um i would say things have been going
pretty well um it's definitely
an adjustment but i wouldn't trade it
for the world
you know like i love my life where it is
now hi
do you mind if i like cultures that no
please
absolutely look at that little cutie ava
rose
oh my gosh so of course we're also
joined here
by caitlin baltierra star of teen mom og
have the two of you had a chance to meet
or connect
no oh no this is the first time wow
well abigail i feel really lucky that we
have caitlyn here with us because
this woman has lived it she has put her
life on television
her marriage and her babies and i'm
curious caitlyn
um is there are there any words of
wisdom
that you want to share with abigail uh
things that maybe you wish you had known
when you first started on this journey
keep doing what you're doing i think you
have a great mindset of how you really
want to focus on school and stuff
um because of course as you probably
know that is going to be so beneficial
to you and your daughter
uh for the future break those statistics
beat those stereotypes of being a young
mom
like oh yeah you you know you thought
this about me will look at me now
type of thing from what you have said
about your boyfriend i think he's an
absolute keeper
and he sounds very supportive and he and
what what you wanted to do from the
beginning
um i think that's amazing because like
you said a lot of teen
moms don't have the support of their
child's father
um and i think it is important too that
yeah you guys are young and you're going
to school like it's going to be crazy
but you know definitely take time for
your relationship as well
um and always i mean you sound like you
have a very
level head i would just say always
putting her first what's best for her
what's going to benefit her in the
future what's going to benefit me as a
mother
um take time for yourself also
um it's very important to have self-care
days
or self-care an hour whatever it is yeah
when it comes to social media and things
in that nature
you've got to have thick skin you're
always gonna have haters there's always
gonna be people that are gonna say
something negative about you
there's always gonna be people that are
gonna judge you for
anything that you do in your life just
know your worth know who you are as a
person
and go off of that i appreciate that so
much you have no idea
oh you're welcome abigail do you have
any specific questions that
you'd love to ask a real pro like
caitlyn
i guess just how do you do it like you
really do amaze me i know that sounds
like so fam girly but like seriously
like i've admired you since the start
and i just don't understand like how you
just wake up every day and you're like
i'm just gonna do this
like it's just crazy to me because i
just live who i
am on the daily basis whether the
cameras are there or not you know
like as long as i stay 100 truthful to
who i am as a person
that's all that matters to me you know
i've struggled i've had my hard days
every day is not perfect
it's like every day is a new day today
is a new day so if i could do something
different
you know i'm gonna do it any tips or
tricks it's about
balancing cameras and a crew and and
then also maintaining like somewhat
privacy and being a family unit uh
privacy goes out the window with this
job
there is no privacy um it is a 24
7 365 days a year job
period it never stops it never goes away
because even if the crew's not there it
is social media
or people stopping you on the streets or
like it never goes away um there is no
privacy i'll say that
but i think it's important too though is
like you know
i set boundaries with my crew if i need
an hour to myself
i'm gonna stick to my guns i'm gonna say
i need an hour thank you i kind of
needed to hear that i'm not gonna lie
well good abigail what's your reaction
to
everything caitlyn just shared i just i
feel like i really didn't need to hear
that i feel like i mean i'm not even a
big part of this i'm one little tiny
episode
out of thousands um and even like
already you know people don't even know
who i
am and they already have negative things
to say and perform
messages and things like that and that
is kind of hard i
really do try to ignore them and just
like block delete but you know sometimes
it does get to you and you do start to
question yourself
and so i just think hearing that from
someone who's been doing it for so long
was is really beneficial she needed that
instilled in me a little bit you know
it is crazy i did not think we were
going to get pregnant anytime soon with
like all the
protection we were using and stuff
because like an ied is supposed to be
like 99.9 something percent
effective i would love if you could just
you know tell us a little bit about
yourself um and a little bit about your
story
um well i actually graduated high school
at 16 that had always been the plan
um and i was you know going to become a
doctor i had all these great
things that i thought was gonna happen
um and
i met my boyfriend like two years ago
now and we just really hit it off and he
really
encouraged me and pushed me to be the
best version of myself
i decided like i should probably be
extra careful
and get on birth control and not have a
baby anytime soon
um and then that kind of just blew up in
my face
and i was really scared to tell people i
didn't tell my mom until
16 weeks because we had already moved
out so i could go to
college um and i really thought like oh
he's gonna leave me like
he doesn't want this we don't like i'm
not ready like that's gonna be a whole
mess and he actually
ended up staying and we ended up working
things out and figuring
out a new plan and i think that we're on
track to
achieve all of our goals it just took a
little bit of rearranging
i would just say like it was very
unexpected i
when i first found out i did not like i
thought that i was dying i really did
not think i was pregnant
uh but i was very like very very sick
and like
miserable my whole pregnancy but
especially in the beginning
and yeah i just think that there's a lot
of
cool interesting i would say like pretty
unique um
things about my story that a lot of
people a lot of teen
parents don't really experience or deal
with
why do you feel that way um well the
birth control that i was on was supposed
to be
pretty effective um but i think that's
really all that i want to say about that
it was just
it was just a complete and out of shock
talk to me about your pregnancy
you were a student and you were kind of
just going about your life day to day
how does your pregnancy
affect what you were dealing with day in
and day out i was still living with my
mom at the time
because we had just signed our lease um
for our apartment and so like
trying to keep like the morning sickness
a secret and like my migraines
and all that was really tough and i
i think because i was keeping it a
secret that made it harder on my body
too
but it really did change how i had to go
about my life
um i really had to like sit down and
think like oh do you really want to
pursue this doctor thing
you know i think with time and just
having the support that i had i was able
to
figure out a new plan and i'm really
excited about it
good well i'm really excited about it
too i know that you
took your studies really seriously and
i'm curious
if you're still in school like what are
your career goals and and what is the
plan moving forward
i am taking this semester off of
college so i just had a baby two months
ago so i wanted to be able to like
figure out how to be a mom and i think
instead of
becoming a doctor at least right away
i'm gonna just pursue nursing
and you know go through that and if
that's something like in the future i'm
like i think i still really want to be a
doctor then i can
handle that when it the time comes but
for now that's the plan
and i'm really excited that i get to
take a little bit more time to be with
my daughter and
yeah spend family time together i'm so
proud of you that's wonderful
um of course you know you mentioned your
daughter
she's here ava rose is here how are
things going how is motherhood
i absolutely love being a mom i've
always wanted to be a mom
obviously not this young but it's just
so amazing like
seeing her smile for the first time and
like
when she's crying and all i have to do
is pick her up and she just is like
content and happy like
i don't know it's just like the most
rewarding thing ever i
didn't expect it to be like as amazing
as it is but like
i swear everything she does i'm like oh
my gosh did you see that she's the most
incredible
creature alive like it's ridiculous how
much i love her
and how much
um that little ava right there next to
you yeah
she was taking me to that look at you
multitasking doing
interview being an adult mother isn't it
crazy that we're about to have a baby
like
soon i'm excited when i found out i was
pregnant
adrian was super supportive from day one
it makes me feel a lot
better knowing that you know he didn't
leave and he wants to be a part of her
life um
during your show we're gonna meet your
boyfriend
adrian um i kind of want to back it up
to the beginning how did he react when
he
discovered that you guys were expecting
a baby from the get-go he was always so
supportive like
you can do this we got this like if you
want to be a mom i want to be a dad like
you make your decision and i'll support
you 110
and i really appreciated that because i
feel like a lot of
teens don't have that support from their
baby's father
and the fact that i was able to just
have that person always in my corner
um i think made my pregnancy a lot
easier and this type of journey of
motherhood a lot easier
wonderful and i know i know parenthood
is a big
adjustment in life what kind of an
impact has becoming
mom and dad had on your romantic
relationship
i think for a bit we kind of forgot that
we were also
supposed to be in a relationship and
we're supposed to like
still hug and kiss and you know pretend
like we like each other
um so i think in the very beginning it
did take a toll and i felt like we were
kind of drifting apart
um but as soon as we realized that and
that it was pointed out
we did start to make it more of a
priority and i think right now we're in
a really good place
and i just hope that it lasts yeah well
speaking of lasts i mean do you think
adrian is the one
is marriage a conversation that the two
of you have i mean we've talked about it
not anytime soon i think we both have a
lot of things we want to achieve before
we worry about
marriage i feel like that's a huge
commitment and a huge responsibility
and to be honest like marriage is a
stressor like you have to make sure that
once you're married you
want to stay married um and i think
we're in a good place we have a really
good dynamic now
and we're also really young like i'm not
in any rush to be like oh i'm a wife
you know like i'm content with being a
mom and his girlfriend i would say that
we there's a good chance we'll end up
married sometime down the line
wonderful well however your journey
continues to unfold
um you certainly have my love and
admiration and support
so the decision to sign up to put your
life on television
um it's a really personal choice and i'm
curious what compelled you to say
let's do this
oh i'm sorry i didn't see that you're
good is she okay
yeah she just wants attention but it's
fine
hi do you mind if i like cultures that
no please
absolutely look at that little cutie ava
rose oh my gosh
to be completely honest i had like no
intentions of even applying
uh my mom just like saw this post on
instagram that they were casting and she
was like you should apply
and i was like why not but i think like
together we all kind of just decided
like
in my opinion in my family's opinion i
was doing everything by the books
correctly and i still got pregnant and i
just wanted to share that part like you
could be doing
everything right and this could still
happen to you um
and it doesn't have to be a negative
thing
and i just really wanted to get that
side of teen parenthood
out there because i feel like it's a lot
of
um like harmful like views like uh the
dad's always gonna leave or
my mom is mad at me or something like
that and i just wanted to show people
that there
is there is a different side of that as
well
um i'm really thankful that they
gave me the opportunity to share that
side yeah
look at you you've got a beautiful
daughter you've got a successful
relationship you're gonna become a nurse
there's nothing negative about your
story abigail absolutely nothing
and i applaud you for for really
shattering those those stereotypes i
just hope that i'm a positive
um influence on people who do see that
because
i just i want i want to be full of
positivity and i want to spread light
and happiness and
i just hope that my story does that for
others
[Music]
[Music]
you